je veux le devenir la plupart des
américains riches partis veulent devenir
riche et la réussite c'est génial notre
métier c'est quoi je suis conseiller en
image d'entreprise
qu'est ce que vous faites
je fais ce que j'aime les magnifiques
toi mais tu dois me faire confiance
regarde toi que je n'avais encore jamais
vu
et c'est l'égalité là pourquoi tu viens
danser
je suis désolé j'avais juste besoin d'un
peu de temps pour te le dire mais jamais
entendre par le toit
julian vous savez que les problèmes
personnels n'ont rien à faire dans la
vie professionnelle du yen ça ne se
reproduira plus heureux de l'entente
soyez vigilants
je ne me laisserai pas emprisonner par
personne
je toujours que tu méritais
je peux tout à fait tes mais aussi fort
que tu souhaites